can't they just get Putin on [ __ ]
FaceTime and go hey did you do that was
that you my boy he's like no no you did
it all we need all we need is body
language experts and then we're good
[Music]
and in another epic moment where JK news
most likely actually reports the news
and if we're not on time edit this part
out but also the news is very
frightening and scary and we might
actually be dead by the time you see
this is this about the bear that was
playing piano that you sent this last
week that was a Hot Topic we're gonna
talk about we're gonna do it on Tuesday
yeah baby I like breaking news it's like
Chopsticks yeah yeah I like that that
story was also super old
it's like hey you guys should cover this
you guys should check this one out to
make this either extra dramatic or just
sound dumb me and Steve are are gonna
read one word at a time together okay
ready are you first Russian missiles
cross into NATO member Poland kill two
senior U.S intelligence that's this is
the one you want to say that I know I
knew it was a bad idea that's why I said
or released does this start world war
three maybe dude it's really just in
case you didn't understand uh Asian Uh
Russian missiles cross into NATO member
of Poland into NATO member Poland that's
really really it always starts
Russian missiles kill two says a senior
U.S intelligence official so is it
aren't they supposed to now have a war
isn't that what happens yo you just
slapped my homie like yeah it's going
down now but but they won't huh so the
post government hasn't hasn't confirmed
this yet that's kind of the
that's it
so if they have butts one spokesperson
told the publication that top leaders
were holding an emergency meeting over
the crisis situation but it's almost
Christmas they need to [ __ ] chill
dude you need to do this and then 2023
bro when should they do a joke
after Easter after Easter okay yeah okay
after the Rapture can we wear white
pants I don't know
so two people were reportedly killed
after a projectile struck an area where
grain was drying in the village of dude
so it hit a straight up Village near the
Ukrainian border yeah but why are U.S
officials there
no no no not U.S officials uh a U.S
intelligence official said this yeah he
thought two U.S officials died in Poland
you worship he thought two official U.S
two official two U.S officials were
launched you thought is that what you
thought
have you ever had a dream that you would
that you would that you would yo that's
crazy if they they hit a [ __ ] grain
silo and two of us officials come
running out yeah like oh [ __ ] they
weren't there oh man in Poland
interesting why is why are they why are
they trying to blow up some bread green
so is it like in the situation where
this happens and then uh the launcher
says oh that was an accident it was a
misfire would that still be the same
result of like we're going to war that
or maybe like hopefully it was one of
those anti-missile things and it hit and
then it just actually landed mate here
maybe you think for that they'll be like
interference they're like you know what
we [ __ ] up yeah we [ __ ] up that's a
pop yeah interference yeah dude oh
that's that's a tough I recently saw
this [ __ ] where um there was actually
a real real incident that was almost
like world war three Cold War World War
Three with nuclear war
and everyone thinks it was Cuba and all
that [ __ ] but they're like the real one
happened when uh us uh boat or sub was
following this like Russian one
and then they thought that [ __ ] was
supposed to happen and they were
supposed to shoot each other
and that would have started like Russia
versus the US direct conflict but then
that uh the Russian side they had a vote
and one dude it had to be a unanimous
vote there were like three captains or
whatever and one Captain was like no I
don't think we should shoot back or we
shouldn't do it
and then so the U.S army
also didn't have radio and they didn't
have radio to Russia so they had to make
a decision and if they if these two
submarines fought we all would have been
like in World War Three yo can we get
them some radios yeah yeah my nieces and
nephews have radios they didn't have
radios but then they made the right
decision because the one Russian officer
that was like nah I don't think we
should shut back that's the takeaway for
that story can we get him some radios
they were underwater they had no
reception I'll buy them I'll buy the
[ __ ] Milwaukee talkies I'm happy to
do it
the uh Pentagon they were out of range
you know Pentagon said that uh they're
taking all reports seriously and looking
into them quote right now we are aware
of the press reporting on this and we
have no information at this time by the
way we're the Press
Sports pentacon press secretary Brig
General Pat Ryder said I don't want to
speculate or get into hypo hypotheticals
when it comes to our security
commitments oh so there's a chance that
this is incorrect completely I think uh
there's always going to be speculation
or anything like that until like
officials officially say something you
don't want to speculate why are you say
it's a Russian missile if you don't know
we don't want to speculate but yeah
that's why it's definitely Russia that's
kind of what I always felt was odd
because I always imagined that World War
III would kind of start like a freaking
like a snap like when the missiles
hitting a NATO member I was like I
thought before we knew it the [ __ ] would
start I didn't know it would be like
we're analyzing the data and we're gonna
see if this is yeah and everybody in the
[ __ ] public gets to actually like
wait for it and like hear everything
word by word right I guess it's not
really like that or maybe that's the
whole point to be like we're analyzing
everything we can't make but really like
everybody in the bag is already gearing
up that's true I didn't think of that
yeah it could be that too like everyone
stay calm kind of [ __ ] right just so but
then in the meantime the shit's flying
through here if we you start seeing like
a bunch of military planes flying
through the air I'll start to [ __ ]
myself for sure the Pentagon press SEC
did say quote we've been crystal clear
that we will defend every inch of NATO
territory in reference to article 5.
Russia's Ministry of Defense denied the
incident so maybe that's also part of it
I don't know whose missiles those are
calling the reports a quote deliberate
provocation in order to escalate the
situation
so I think it's pretty escalated guys
yeah you're blowing up a lot of things I
just passed that point it's pretty
pretty heightened already well this is
like two people in like in a fight in
the circle and all the friends around
waiting to jump in yeah right and then
like so like you said somebody just
[ __ ] accidentally swing somebody yeah
that would I didn't mean to hit your
gang member buddy well I haven't I have
alliance with these guys dude and that's
how [ __ ] World War One and Two
started bro yeah but you know hey like
in a way like I don't want this to
happen but I am interested on how
today's Young Generation would react to
a draft
um hey I'm signing up brother I'm a
patron I feel like on both sides it'll
just be like cool I don't want to do it
because you heard about the Russian
soldiers they didn't
went on and then they're like oh [ __ ]
and then they just was like I said the
guys on the Eastern Front yeah when they
first started they're like I thought it
was a military I thought it was
exercises yeah and then when dudes were
shooting at them they're like what the
[ __ ] and then they deserted they thought
they were like in an X-Men Danger Room
yeah like this is real I will say I
remember having the feeling um again I
was only 16 at a time but when 2011 2001
happened on September 11th I do remember
if there was a draft I probably would
have signed up
I just remember that feeling I remember
filling out my draft card when I was 18
and being like this shit's real because
it was in that zone like we were going
to war with Iraq when I turned 18. so it
was like [ __ ] this is real [ __ ] damn I
wanted to join the military once I can
see
um or maybe maybe I've just been
watching way too many Hollywood films
but the idea of like uh you know
starting some [ __ ] in some undercover
way in order to get like people at War
right like like the propaganda or like
the maybe it wasn't Russia maybe it was
somebody else who was uh willing to do
something and sacrifice something in
order to get bigger players in right
like uh you know would you put it past
hypothetic allegedly well hypothetically
would you put it past like um uh
Ukraine even you know what I mean to be
like oh dude well if we send this
missile into a NATO territory we call it
Russian then maybe people will come out
and help us maybe we'll get military
backing yeah you know what I'm saying
I'm again I'm not saying that but like
we've seen enough [ __ ] up movies and
stuff and we've also seen you know those
different types of conspiracies where
it's like same thing if something's like
an inside job in order to start
something else it's like yeah because
historically that's happened yeah yeah
that's that's a thing yeah yeah so even
with with Russia right now saying things
like what did they say officially no
strikes were made against Targets near
the Ukrainian Polish state border by
Russian means of Destruction Russia
officially said in a statement it's like
who do you believe sometimes doesn't
matter
because the outcome matters is it is it
very difficult to trace the origin of a
missile
so then
find the laundry Direction tag is gone
yeah yeah the barcodes blowed up made in
Russia the serial number scratched off
so you don't know where it came from
it's like this was made in China
it sucks up its own smoke as it flies
that was probably my you know one of the
most interesting Parts about the 911
attacks for me is they found all their
passports like in a New York Street of
like the hijackers they're finding like
the hijackers passports like intact just
littered it's like yeah we found them
yep okay we got some passports over here
oh look at what we found is that really
what they said they just straight up
found it on the top of the rubble I'm
just saying like yeah that happened but
it's a hell of a coincidence
passport sniffing dogs though
passport sniffing dogs the cute little
beagles they found hundreds of passports
yeah they were finding out passports
everywhere
well that's another thing about the pipe
that they blew up right oh yeah the one
that goes from Russia to England or
wherever
um but Russia blew up Cheers Cheers but
according to Russia that England blew up
and according to Jake Tran yeah he had a
whole thing about that too it's pretty
interesting yeah National Security
Council spokesperson Adrian Watson took
the Twitter to confirm that the White
House is quote working with the Polish
government to gather more information we
cannot confirm the reports or any of the
details at the time we will determine
what happened and what the appropriate
next steps would be can't they just get
Putin on [ __ ] FaceTime and go hey
all we need all we need is body language
experts and then we're good
they're always right they're always
right they're 100 correct and they can
work from home you know because they're
always on Zoom dude and like L.A Noir
just [ __ ] watch the face I just don't
want war to happen because like why I
say they get Putin on a FaceTime they
have one of the they have two of the
body language experts from YouTube look
at it and if they say that he looks
guilty then yeah we go world war three
or just get him get him on a like an
Instagram truth filter where it like
calculates if you're lying what really
happens uh once like uh so somebody
somewhere in NATO gets bombed or
whatever everybody has to everybody as a
part of NATO has to jump in that's what
I thought but I feel like that's not a
thing or is it one of those things where
it's like yeah that's the pack
and then it's like what what actually
happened it's like oh it's I mean it's a
small it was a great only two people
died and people were like we don't
really want to go to war modern I feel
like modern warfare isn't the way that
we used to think that it would be no
it's a PS5 now been happening and it's
very much commercial and like industrial
and that's why everything's [ __ ] well
post 911 what wasn't NATO involved with
like the campaigns in Afghanistan Iraq
and all that [ __ ] there were NATO
Nations but not all of them no like the
UK joined maybe it's more like that
maybe it's more selective yeah some some
of them didn't but then I don't think
it's because they got attacked on their
soil I guess you could call 911 that but
then like yeah dude I remember Bush
being like we got a coalition hola a lot
of member countries and then you look it
up you look it up and it's like France
sent like 14 dudes
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] baby laughs why even bother
like what a coalition dude thanks man
those are 14 Brave Frenchmen yeah
they're super soldiers dude
[Music]